los inicios de campaña muy distintos
pero separados por unos pocos kilómetros
el sábado el ex presidente y candidato
presidencial de lula da silva se dio un
baño de masas en salvador de bahía
coincidiendo con el día de su
independencia a los colonizadores a tres
meses de los comicios presidenciales en
brasil el izquierdista parte como
favorito según los sondeos con el 47 por
ciento de intención de voto
encontramos el
presente en che lo vemos como nuestro
presidente quizás la figura pública viva
más importante de la historia de brasil
y es imposible no emocionarse con sus
palabras y no dejarse guiar por este
horizonte de esperanza las palabras no
se verían nada por eso te espero
rodeado por una multitud de
motociclistas y su esquema de seguridad
el presidente y air bolsonaro se subió a
su moto para saludar a sus seguidores
bolsonaro se lanza a la reelección con
un 28% de intención de votos según las
encuestas algo que ha disparado las
alarmas en la campaña del líder
ultraderechista que deja el país con una
inflación del 12 por ciento de desempleo
del 10% y 33 millones de personas
pasando hambre
para mostrar que estamos apuntando a la
reelección de nuestro presidente ya ir
mesías bolsonaro y necesitamos esta
reelección de nuestro presidente dos
veces se espera que el próximo 2 de
octubre se decida el futuro de la
presidencia en brasil de momento las
encuestas pronostican que lula da silva
podría vencer en primera vuelta